اهلا بكم في هذه التغطيه المستمره للزلزال
في يومه السادس وتحديدا نحن الان فيها تاي
نكمل هذه التغطيه مع مراسلنا ووفدنا
للمنفذ العربيه عمار الهندي من موقع
استخراج شخص تمت هذه هذه المحاولات دامت
لمده تتجاوز الاربع ساعات الان على الهواء
ومع عمار اذهب اليك عمار
هل هناك اي تحديثات حول
الاوضاع لهذه الامراه الموجوده داخل هذه
الحفره في هذا البيت المهدوم
اسمحي لي سريعا حنين ان اذكر المشاهدين
بما يحدث هنا هذا مبنى منهار في انطاكيا
وسط ولايه هاتاي هذا المبنى لم تعمل به
فرق الانقاذ بدات فيه اليوم كان هنالك
فريق انقاذ وسمع صوتا وحركه وحينما يعني
خاطب الشخص تحت الانقاض كانت هنالك رده
فعل جلبوا فريق التعزيزات بالاجهزه
المتطوره وحينما جاء الفريق قام الفريق
بفحص هذا الجهاز وتبين بالفعل ان هنالك
شخص تحت الانقاض على قيد الحياه
وبعدها قاموا بسؤاله بالطلب منه ان يجيب
من خلال ردات فعل معينه على اسئلتهم اجابت
هذه الفتاه على اسئلتهم بمعنى انه اذا
جابت حيه اجابت هناك ادراك ادراك لديها
وقامت بالاجابه
عند لديها ادراك واضح وادراك كامل للامر
وبعد ذلك تاكدوا انها على قيد الحياه
تحدثت الى الضابط المسؤول عن الذي عمل على
الجهاز واكد لي انها على قيد الحياه ومن
ثم ابلغني بانها انثى وانها شابه يعني
فتاه لا استطيع ان احدد عمرها حتى هذه
اللحظه حينما سالتهم عن المده الزمنيه
التي يحتاجونها
للعمل اخبرني بانه خلال ساعه ولكن تجاوزنا
هذه الساعه هم جلبوا دعامات خشبيه
لعدم ضمان عدم انهيار السقف الذي يعملون
من تحته لديهم مولدات ولديهم الاجهزه
ولديهم كل شيء يحتاجونه هو الاضاءه تعمل
هنا على مولدات طبعا كان هنالك استنفار
وجلبوا العديد من رجال الانقاذ والخبراء
ليتمكنوا من الوصول اليها وطبعا حفروا في
السقف
حدثوا فتحه في السقف والفتحه الثانيه من
تحت من تحت السقف الغرفه حيث وضعت
الدعامات الخشبيه
نعم هم يستخدمون دعامات من الحديد ودعامات
من الخشب لضمان عدم انهيار هذا السقف
الذين الذي يعملون تحته دخل منذ قليل احد
رجال الانقاذ يعني ادخل نصف جسده ليتفقد
المكان هم طبعا يحاولون ان يجتازوا هذه
المسافه التي تفصلهم للعثور على هذه
الفتاه وسحبها من تحت الانقاض واعادتها
مجددا الى الحياه وبالتالي طبعا هذه
المسافه رغم قصرها وانها ربما لا تتجاوز
امتار لكنها في الواقع
رغم حنين لا ادري ان كنت تسمعين جيدا وكنت
اقول ان هذه المسافه رغم قصارها ورغم انها
لا تتجاوز ربما امتار بسيطه ولكنها في
الواقع تحتاج الى الكثير من الصبر الكثير
من الوقت في سبيل الوصول الى هذه الفتاه
التي هي على قيد الحياه ما نستطيع ان نؤكد
بحسب ما اخبرنا به هنا عناصر من السلاح
الهندسه التركي بانها على قيد الحياه
واخبرتني ايضا منقذه بانها على قيد الحياه
وانه هنالك اصوات تصدر وهي حيه رغم انها
لليوم السادس على التوالي تتواجد تحت
الانقاض وهذا ليس بغريب بعد ان اخرجت
اليوم طفله في قهرمان مرعش والان الان شخص
اخر فبالتالي الامل حنين موجود
دعني اسالك عمار هل حط اي اختلاف في
الادوات التي تستخدم حاليا يعني في هذه
المرحله الحساسه من انقاذ هذه السيده او
لا نعلم عمرها بالضبط ولكن هل لاحظت
اختلاف في الادوات
نعم نعم استخدام الاجهزه الحديثه احدث
فارقا كبيرا صراحه لانهم ما عاد البحث
عشوائي وما عاد الاستماع للاصوات عشوائي
ربما يعني حينما بداوا باستخدام هذه
الاجهزه بدات العمليه ادق واسهل لانه
لضمان ربما عدم تكرار ما حدث في اكثر من
حاله بانهم حينما يعني تاكدوا من في بعض
الحالات ان اشخاص على قيد الحياه
استغرقهم الامر وقت طويل وهذا الوقت
الطويل حاله دون الوصول اليها او اليه حسب
الشخص يعني على قيد الحياه مثلا امس كنا
شاهدنا حاله مشابهه لهذا الامر كانت سيده
محاميه
حيه على قيد الحياه في مكان اخر وكانوا
يسمعون كانت كان لها انين صوت انين تتالم
عرفوا انها على قيد الحياه وتاكدوا ولكن
استغرق الامر اكثر من ثلاث ساعات ونصف
حينما وصلوا اليها كانت فارقت الحياه ربما
لعدم عدم استخدام الاجهزه ربما لان ما
اعاق عملهم واعترض طريقهم كان اكبر من
قدرتهم على حل المشكله لا اعلم لماذا ولكن
في النهايه
[موسيقى]
حنين انا يؤسفني انني فقدت الاتصال معك
ساصمت واعطيك الصوره لحين ان يعود الاتصال
معك هل تسمعني الان عمار
اذا سنكمل سنتابع هذه التغطيه لهذه
العمليه لانقاذ السيده في هاتاي انطاكيا
مع موفدنا هناك عمار الهندي ولكن سنذهب
الان الى بعض الاخبار في هذه التغطيه
المستمره لليوم السادس وفي هذه الليله خيم
الليل وارخى الظلام ستاره على هذا اليوم
من كارثه الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا يختلط
القليل من الامل بالكثير من الالم
والخيبات والنحيب على اكثر من 27 الف
قتيلا قضوا في الرقعه المنكوبه تركيا لها
الحصه الاكبر من العداد باكثر من 22
واعمل الانقاذ تشارف على الانتهاء في جميع
المدن المنكوبه بحسب مفوض الاغاثه الامميه
اما في سوريا ارتفع عدد القتلى الى خمسه
الاف ومئتي شخص الدفاع المدني السوري اكد
انه تم الانتهاء من عمليات الانقاذ وتم
البدء في عمليات رفع الانقاذ لانتشال
الجثث بعدما اصبحت فرص العثور على الناجين
شبه معدومه لا احياء خرجوا من تحت الركام
في اخر 36 ساعه اذا عداد يسابق عدادا اخر
والتوقعات بالحصيله الاسوا جاءت من الامم
المتحده 40 الف شخص واكثر قد تكون الحصيله
النهائيه
[موسيقى]
الشيخ
ولا تزال جوله الرئيس التركي الى المناطق
المتضرره مستمره ومن محطه ديار بكر
المنكوبه اكد اردوغان ان الزلزال الاخير
لا يمكن مقارنته بالزلزال او الزلازل
السابقه كشف ايضا عن رقم مهم وهو حوالي 14
مليون شخص تضرروا بسبب الكارثه التي جعلت
من مئات الالاف مئات الاف المباني غير
صالحه للسكن وللتذكير اقوى زلزلين ضرب
تركيا كان في عامي
1999 في ازميد وايضا
1939 زلزالو ارزنجان شرق البلاد والذي
استشهد به اردوغان قبل ايام لوصف هول
الزلزال الاخير
لا يمكن مقارنه هذا الزلزال بالزلازل
السابقه قمنا بزيارات وجولات الى جميع
الولايات المتضرره وادركنا عن قرب وعن كثب
ان تركيا تعيش كارثه حقيقيه جميع العلماء
في العالم تحدثوا عن قوه هذه الهزات
الزلزاليه واضيف ان اكثر من 14 مليون
مواطن تضرروا بسبب هذين الزلزالين
الكبيرين بالاضافه الى الضرر الذي تسببت
فيه الهزات الارتداديه بذلنا قصر جهدنا من
اجل الوصول الى جميع المناطق المتضرره
واعتقد بان العدد الاجمالي للمتضررين
والمنكوبين سيصل الى 20 مليون شخص من
الذين يعيشون في المناطق المنكوبه
والمناطق المحيطه بها ازيزلان الكبيران
كان مدمرين للغايه فمئات الالاف من
المباني لم تعد صالحه للسكن
كثيره فوق الارض لعلها تجد استجابه تحتها
مشاهد تدفع للتساؤل من يستجد بمن مقطع
متداول لابن تركي يصرخ باسماء افراد
عائلته املا في اي اشاره على بقائهم احياء
تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
ولا تزال عمليه رفع الانقاض مستمره طبعا
وننوه الى هذا العاجل وزير الصحه التركيه
اكد ارتفاع عدد القتلى في تركيا الى 22 و
327 شخصا اذا هذه احدث حصيله للضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا فقط اما في سوريا فخمسه
الافئتين حتى الان السلام عليكم اول ما
نطقت الطفله رنا جاما البالغه من العمر 12
عاما بمجرد انقاذها ما جعل رجال الانقاذ
والحشد يهللون من حولها لنتابع
[موسيقى]
لذلك الطفله رنا جام انضمت الى مئات وربما
الاف الاطفال الذين تم انقاذهم بجهود فرق
الانقاذ في المناطق المنكوبه التركيه
العشر لكن الكثير من هؤلاء الاطفال فقدوا
ابائهم واوسرهم حول مصيرهم وزاره الاسره
والخدمات الاجتماعيه في تركيا اوضحت ان
هؤلاء الاطفال سيقيمون في دور رعايه او
لدى اسر حاضنه
لم يكتفي الزلزال بتحطيم منازلهم لم يكتفي
بسرقه اسرهم بل سلب من هؤلاء الاطفال حتى
اسمائهم
[موسيقى]
مجهول كل التفاصيل حاضره اين تم العثور
عليهم كيف ومتى لكن غاب شيء اخر مهم
عنوانهم هوياتهم من هم والى من ينتمون
في تركيا يحاولون مطابقه الاطفال
المجهولين بالعناوين لكن في الغالب لا
تكون العناوين اكثر من انقاض وفقا لوزاره
الاسره والخدمات الاجتماعيه في تركيا
سيقيموا هؤلاء الاطفال في دور رعايه او
لدى اسر حاضنه في حال انتهت جميع محاولات
التوصل الى اسرهم او اقاربهم حيث تم
الاعلان عن ارقام للتواصل في حال الرغبه
باحتضان اطفال من ضحايا الزلزال فيما تلقت
الوزاره اكثر من 95 الف طلب لحضانه هؤلاء
الاطفال حتى الان
مقابله شروط للتبني وضعتها سلطات التركيه
من الزلزال لكنهم وقعوا في اخر قذف بهم في
مصير غامض تم لم شمل بعضهم لكن كثيرين ما
زالوا اطفالا مجهولين هويه الزلزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
[موسيقى]
في سوريا توقفت عمليات الانقاذ والبحث
اعلنها دفاع المدني السوري وشكى مسؤوله
مرارا من نقص الامكانات لرفع الانقاذ في
غياب معدات ثقيله اليوم في سادس ايام
الكارثه نشرت الخوه البيضاء مقطع فيديو
يظهر عمليه انقاذ رضيعه على قيد الحياه
تعود الى فجر اليوم الاول من وقوع الزلزال
في مدينه جنديرس ريف حلب
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على السلامه
بسم الله
الله اكبر
وصفه مالتي مسؤوله المساعدات في الامم
المتحده الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا باسوء حدث تشهده هذه المنطقه في
مئه عام وكشف المسؤول الامميه عن وجود خطه
من ثلاثه اشهر سيتم اتخاذها لاغاثه
المناطق المنكوبه في كل من سوريا وتركيا
كما اعرب عن امله في ان تصل المساعدات في
سوريا الى المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره النظام
والمعارضه على حد سواء لكنه شدد على ان
الامر لم يتضح بعد
ما حدث هنا يوم الاثنين الماضي حين ضرب
الزلزال هذه المنطقه يعد اسوا حدث منذ مئه
سنه الاستجابه كما شهدناها هنا تعد نادره
حيث لم يكن هناك استجابه دوليه ومحليه
لكارثه طبيعيه مثل هذه الايام العصيبه
كشف رئيس منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس
ادهنوم خلال مؤتمر صحفي في حلب المنكوبه
كشف عن تقديم مستلزمات طبيه الى سوريا
بنحو 37 طنا مشددا على ان المنظمه ستقدم
المزيد
في الاثناء قالت مديره اداره البرامج
بالمكتب الاقليمي للشرق المتوسط التابع
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه رنا الحجه قالت ان
نحو 200 الف سوري بمحافظه حلب باتوا بلا
جراء الدمار الذي الحقه الزلزال بمباني
المدينه وحفت في مؤتمر صحفي المجتمع
الدولي على تقديم المزيد من المساعدات
لاغاثه ضحايا الزلزال
اود ان اشدد على ان المجتمع الدولي قدم
الكثير من الالتزامات وعبر عن اراده كبيره
في حشد المساعده هناك الكثير من الجهود
المبدوله لتقديم المساعدات للمتضررين لكن
لا تزال هناك حاجه ماسه لزياده المساعدات
لان حجم الدمار هائل
من جانبه قال مدير الطوارئ الاقليميه
بالشرق المتوسط التابع لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه
ان منظمه الصحه تحشد المجتمع الدولي لجمع
اكثر من اربعين مليون دولار لزياده دعم
المتضررين من الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا
بثلاثه واربعين طنا من المساعدات نحن لا
نقوم بمازل عن بقيه شركائنا في الحكومه
التقينا في الايام الماضيه ثلاث مرات
مسؤولي وزاره الصحه حتى نقف على
احتياجاتهم بشكل دقيق نعمل بشكل وثيق مع
شركائنا في الامم المتحده والمنظمات غير
الحكوميه للحصول على المزيد من المساعدات
اعتقد انه مع مرور كل ساعه ومع مرور كل
يوم يتحسن العمل الاغاثي بشكل اكبر منظمه
الصحه العالميه توجه نداء لجمع اكثر من 40
مليون
وبذلك سنتمكن من زياده المساعدات التي
يحتاجها ضحايا الزلزال في شمال سوريا نحن
بحاجه للتمويل وسياده المساعدات ودعم
زملائنا السوريين حتى يقدموا المساعدات
للمحتاجين خصوصا في ظل ترد القطاع الصحي
في سوريا
اول مره بتصير هيك بهالفجعه هيك بهالج انا
ما مر علي هيك والله اي حركه عم نحس دائما
صار في تشقق بالبيت صار في يعني ريان
بالبيت يعني
فاضطريت للجامات تيجي اللجنه
ولاجل هذه المعاناه التي تحدث عنها سوريون
المعابر الحدوديه بين تركيا وسوريا هي طوق
النجاه الاخير للناجين من هول الزلزال
المدمر في شمال غرب سوريا نتعرف عليها
[موسيقى]
جونا هنا في شمال غرب سوريا المنكوبه
حياتهم مرهونه بحبل نجاه اخير يتمثل بفتح
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا كي تعود الحياه
شبه طبيعيه بعد زلزال قضى على البشر
والحجر
لكن ما هي اهم المعابر الحدوديه بين سوريا
وتركيا وايها يعمل ليكون شريان حياه لاكثر
من اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا
معبر باب الهوى هو حاليا المعبر الرسمي
الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي تسيطر عليه المعارضه السوريه
معبر باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب
تسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه السوريه معبر
جرابلس في ريف حلب تسيطر عليه فصائل
المعارضه السوريه ايضا
دوليا المنظمات الامميه طالبت النظام
السوري بتسهيل مرور المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه من دون قيد او شرط اما مجلس
الامن فسيعقد الاسبوع المقبل جلسه لمناقشه
امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده بارسال
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر اكثر من
معبر حدودي
بدوره النظام السوري اعلن موافقته على
ايصال مساعدات للمناطق المتضرره الخارجه
عن سيطرته واستردد تركي بعد ان قالت انقره
انها تدرس قرارها محاسن حضاره العربيه
سنعود الى تركيا لمتابعه عمليه الانقاذ من
هاتاي مع موفده العربيه عمار عمار هندي
عمار اي تطور في هذه العمليه التي تستمر
لاكثر من اربع ساعات الان على الهواء
نحن نترقب ما يحدث هنا ولكن للتو حدثت هزه
ارتداديه شعرنا بها بشكل كبير كل من هنا
فوق المبنى شعر بها بشكل واضح يبدو انها
ضربت
انطاكيا وهاتاي عموما على ايه حال
العمليات مستمره هم يواصلون اعمالهم
للوصول الى هذه السيده تحت الانقاض وهم في
حاله استنفار ولكن لا يمكن لاحد ان يفعل
شيء امام ما يحدث هنا يعني الصبر في هذه
العمليه مطلوب والعمليات احيانا تاخذ وقت
وتستغرق وقت لانه اذا اعترضهم شيء وهنا لك
ان تتخيلي حنين يعني انا وانت ومن يشاهد
ويعني هذه لحظات الترقب التي يعني نتابعها
ومن اصابه الفضول لرؤيه هذه السيده وهي
تخرج هذا كله يجب ان نقارنه بمن هو تحت
الانقاض وكيف يشعر منذ سته ايام وهو يعني
ربما هذه السيده ربما كانت لايام تصرخ
وتنادي وتحاول ان توصل صوتها ولكن لا احد
يسمعها يعني الامر هنا
قلت ان العمليه بدات اليوم عمليه الانقاذ
الوصول الى هذا المبدا في هذه المنطقه في
هذا الحي الذي اتواجد نعم نعم في هذا الحي
الذي اتواجد فيه العمليات بدات اليوم يعني
انا في في مبنى اخر مجاور لهذه البنايه
التي انا على سقفها هنالك عفوا هنالك
عائله سوريه لا تزال تحت الانقاض وانا
رايت
شاب ينتظر امه واخوته تحت الانقاض
وبالتالي
العمليات لم تكن وصلت الى هذا الحي لان
كما قلت لك وكما يعلم الجميع رقعه الدمار
هائله جدا وبالتالي هنالك اسئله كثيره
تحتاج الى اجابات لمن الاولويه كيف يحدد
الاولويه كيف يستدل على الصوت يعني الكثير
من الاسئله من خلال مشاهداتنا تحتاج الى
اجابات لا ربما لا يجيب عليها احد انا
اعتقد انه لن يجيب عليها احد من سيجيب على
سؤال لماذا تعطوا الاولويه لهذه البنايه
او هذا الحي
يعني
تستثنوا حيا اخر او تؤجل العمل فيه ربما
يعني تكون الاجابه اننا لا نستطيع الوصول
اليها الا حينما ننتهي مثلا من البنايات
التي تسبقها او الاحياء التي تسبقها هذا
امر معقد
نذكر
اليوم تحدث وقال ان اعداد
افراد وعناصر فرق الانقاذ تصل الى 160
الفا ولكن ايضا لا ننسى انه اعترف بالامس
عن وقوع بعض الاخطاء في عمليات الانقاذ
انطاكيا من المدن المعروف انها تعرضت
لتاخير كبير في عمليات الانقاذ لو تعطينا
لمحه يعني اوضح عن المنطقه بينما ننتظر
ونشاهد يعني عمليه الانقاذ هذه ولكن بشكل
اشمل عن المنطقه المحيطه بهذا المبنى
نعم نعم بكل تاكيد اولا يعني باعتراف وزير
الصحه التركي يوم امس بان انطاكيا هي اكثر
المدن التركيه التي تعرضت لدمار وهي
وهاتاي عموما هي اكثر ولايه كان فيها
ضحايا من جراء هذا الزلزال المدينه كبيره
جدا طبعا ولايه هاتاي كبيره جدا وفيها
احياء سكنيه كبيره جدا ولكنها مدمره
بالكامل هنالك دمار في كل مكان في احياء
كامله تدمرت ويعني بنايات
بالعشرات تدمرت في نفس الوقت
دمرت بنفس الوقت
هم يعني احدهم يعطيني ماء الان اشعرنا
بانني احتاج الى الماء واعطاني ماء نعم
هنالك بنايات واحياء كثيره كبيره باكملها
تدمرت حنين وتاخر العمل فيها هنالك احياء
بدل بدا العمل فيها اليوم واحياء بدا
العمل فيها امس واحياء لم يبدا العمل فيها
بعد وانا رايت كل هذا يعني انا اليوم وانا
اجوب في انطاكيا في في وسط المدينه
[موسيقى]
هذه هذه الاصوات فقط احاول ان افهم ما
الذي يحدث
سنبقى سنبقى معك عمار يطلبون الصمت
والسكوت
نعم طلب من موفدنا في هاتايا في انطاكيا
الان وهو ينقل لنا هذه العمليه عمليه
الانقاذ طلب منه الصمت وهكذا جرت العاده
في هذه الايام
الست الماضيه في اي عمليه انقاذ يطلب من
المحيطين بالمبنى
بالصمت
لربما يحصلون على اشاره على صوت على دلاله
ربما يحاولون التواصل مع من هم تحت
الانقاذ في هذا المبنى تحديدا هناك سيده
او فتاه لا زلنا لا نعلم
يحاولون اخراجها من تحت الركام منذ ساعات
تاخرت العمليه بعد الشيء ولكنها الان كما
تحدث وقال مفدنا هناك عمار الهندي انها في
المراحل الحساسه كونها تجاوزت الساعه وهي
المده التي قالوا لها قالوا له فرق
الانقاذ ان ستتم بعدها عمليه الانقاذ اذا
اخذت المزيد من الوقت لكن ربما هذه هي
المراحل الاخيره من هذه العمليه تحديدا
وان
اقفال اغلاق
المصابيح والنور في هذه المرحله ربما هي
للوصول ربما لا نعلم ستتكشف الان ولكن طلب
منه الصمت وايضا اغلقت الانوار والمصابيح
اذا سنبقي اعيننا مع هذه العمليه ونتمنى
ان يبقى مثنى عمار امنا كانت هناك هزه
ارتداديه تحدث عنها شعرت بها كلها طاين
نذكر بان اداره الكوارث التركيه تحدثت
اليوم ايضا وقالت ان الهزات الارتداديه
ستستمر في تركيا وتحديدا ستكون بين اربع
درجات وسته درجات اذا نتمنى السلامه
لفرق الانقاذ وايضا لفريقنا في تركيا
وسنبقى معهم ولكن نعود اليهم بعد هذه
الاخبار لدينا اذا اعلن رئيس قسم الحد من
المخاطر باداره الطوارئ والكوارث في تركيا
اورخان اتترام اعلن ان الزلازل الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد في السادس من فبراير
استمر لدقيقتين وعادل من وجهه النظر
العلميه انفجار في 500 قنبله ذريه
يوسف
وان كانت احاديه تاثيرها مهول الزلزال كما
ذكرت اداره الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
يعادل بقوته 500 قنبله ذريه الحقيقه
العلميه الجيولوجيه تؤكد ان هناك اكثر من
مليون هزه ارضيه تحدث كل عام بقوه اثنين
ريختر توازي هذه الدرجه سته وخمسين كيلو
غراما من المتفجرات نادرا ما يشعر بها
البشر خاصه وان بؤره الزلزال تقع على عمق
كيلومترات تحت الارض كذلك الامر في الدرجه
الثالثه من الزلزال وهي تعادل 2800 كيلو
جرام من المتفجرات وتمثل نبضات خفيفه
بوتيره مئه الف مره في العام الواحد
اما في الزلزال من الدرجه الرابعه على
مقياس ريختر ومعدل حدوثها عشره الاف مره
في السنه على مستوى العالم فان الزلزال
الواحد يوازي انفجار سته وخمسين الف كيلو
جراما من المتفجرات نعم هنا يبدا الحديث
فوق الارض عن زلزال يشعر بها به من عليها
وان بتفاوت ايضا يبقى المعدل مقبولا
بالمناسبه حتى عند الدرجه الخامسه على
مقياس ريختر فهي درجه يسجلها اكثر من 1500
زلزال سنويا يوازي كل منها انفجار مليون
و800 الف كيلو جرام من متفجرات التي ان تي
طبعا الدرجه مع اعشارها تحدث فرقا لكن من
هذه النقطه الان تبدا مراحل الخطر الدرجه
السادسه هي قوه قنبله هيروشيما القوات
تعادل سته وخمسين مليون
جرام من المتفجرات وصلنا الان الى ترجمه
ما قالته اداره الكوارث في محاكاتنا
الدرجه السابعه توازي انفجار مليار و800
مليون كيلو جرام زلزال تركيا الاول الذي
وقع في غازي عنتاب كان اقرب الى الثمان
درجات سته وخمسون مليارا من المتفجرات هذا
ما تعادله قوته
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الضخم الذي وصفته الامم المتحده
بالحدث الاسوا في المنطقه منذ 100 عام
اعاد للواجهه سؤالا الجدليا هل يمكن توقع
الزلازل او التنبؤ بها هيئه المسح
الجيولوجيه الامريكيه في رغم ان هناك
علماء يتوقعون ويصيبون الهيئه تصف الامر
بانه حتى الساعه المتوقفه تكون صحيحه
مرتين في اليوم وتفرق بين التوقع والتنبؤ
فبين عامي
2010 تم تحليل
548 زلزالا قويا 20 منها فقط تم التنبؤ
بها بشكل او باخر في الصين منتصف يناير
عام
1975 تنبات بكين بزلزال على المدى القصير
في منطقه
وذلك بناء على ملاحظات جيو فيزيائيه وعلى
سلوك الحيوانات غير الطبيعي في الرابع من
فبراير حدث التنبؤ فعلا زلزال ضخمه بدرجه
7.3 لكن بسبب التنبؤ اختار كثيرون البقاء
خارج منازلهم بالتالي عدد القتلى لم يكن
ضخما اقل من 300 شخص هذا النوع من الزلزال
او الزلازل المدمره نادرا ما يتبعه نشاط
زلزاليا كبير فقط يتم توقع الهزات
الارتداديه الاقل وبالتالي ما حدث بعدها
بعام لم يتم التنبؤ به او توقعه يوليو
1976 وتحديدا في مدينه تشانغ شان الزلزال
ضخم بقوه اكبر
7.8 درجات وبالنتيجه كانت النتيجه كارثيه
وما لا يقل عن 240 الف شخص قضوا فيه اما
وجهه النظر الاخرى التي يرفضها اغلب
العلماء تقول انه يمكن التوقع بناء على
مواقع الكواكب وهو ما استند اليه الباحث
الهولندي فران في تنبؤ بزلزالي تركيا
وسوريا
بدراسه للبروفيسور العراقيه الدكتور صالح
محمد عوض وهي بعنوان محاذاه الكواكب تؤدي
الى الزلزال وهو ينضم الينا الان عبر
سكايب اهلا بك دكتور الصالح اذا استشهد
الباحث الهولندي فرانك هوجربيت بدراستك
التي تتحدث عن حركه الكواكب لو امكن ان
تشرح لنا بشكل مبسط هذه النظريه تقربها
اكثر لنا وللمشاهدين
شكرا جزيلا لك ولمشاهدي قناه الحدث اصحح
معلومه ولم العربيه
نعم قناه العربيه عفوا هو لم يشير الى
بحثي فقط وانما استند على المفاهيم التي
انا وضعتها ولاول مره في العالم
الشيء الجديد الذي وضعته هو اضفته مفاهيم
جديده تتلخص بان سبب الزلزال مرتبط
ارتباطا وثيقا باسباب خارجيه اي كونيه
اضافه الى الداخليه
كيف دكتور صالح كيف تتعلق بالكواكب نعم
نعم ساجيبك مثال بسيط حتى يفهم المشاهدين
لان لا استطيع ان اتكلم بالعلم الصرف مثلا
المد والجزر والزلازل ناتجه عن ترتيب
كواكب النظام الشمسي الذي يسلط قوه جاذبيه
واجهاد على الصفائح الارضيه مما يسبب
تغيير سرعه دوران الارض حول نفسها ما يسمى
بالروتيشن ودوران الارض في محورها حول
الشمس ما يسمى
وهذا لاول مره يذكر اي ان اليوم الواحد
ليس كل يوم هو 24 ساعه بل قد يقل او يزيد
بجزء من الثانيه وليس كل سنه هي 365 يوم
قد قد تزود او تقل وقد حسبت هذا في لتسع
احداث
كونيه كبيره وحدثت فيها زلازل يحصل دكتور
كيف يساعد كل هذا لو سمحت لي عشان وقت
المقابله كيف يساعد كل ذلك في التنبؤ
بزلزال وهل نستطيع التنبؤ او توقع زلزال
هناك فارق طبعا
بمده زمنيه معينه ام هناك موعد محدد يمكن
تحديده ممكن ان نقول في هذه السنه ربما
يقع زلزال ام سنقول في الشهر مثلا شهر
فبراير سيقع زلزال في المنطقه الفلانيه او
في المنطقه المحدده هذه
شكرا جزيلا عزيزتي حتى يفهم المشاهد لازم
اكمل الفكره يعني هي انا لا اتكلم الا
بالماده العلميه وليس على السوشيال ميديا
طبعا كل الاحترام دكتور ولكن ايضا نحن ضمن
تغطيه وهناك تغطيه الان فكنا نود ان
نبسطها اكثر سنترك لك المجال ولكن في
عجاله رجاء
يحصل الزلزال نتيجه للتباطؤ او التسارع
النسبي
لسرعه الدورانيه للارض حول نفسها وحول
الشمس هذا التسارع والتباطؤ هو سببه وضع
الوضع الكوكبي الذي يتغير في كل لحظه منذ
ان خلق الارض الله الارض ولحد الان فيما
يخص هل يتم
التوقع ام لا طبعا هذا سؤال وجيه وذكي
ويجب ان يطرح ونجيب عليه طبعا المفاهيم
الجديده التي طرحتها في بحثي تتحدث عن
احتماليه حدوث الزلزال اقول احتماليه حدوث
الزلزال من خلال حسابات فلكيه منها نحدد
اي المناطق اصبحت تحت جهد عالي ومن ثم
تكون مرشحه لحدوث الزلزال وهنا قد يحدث
الزلزال في الزمن المحسوب حتما او قد
يتقدم قليلا او يتاخر قليلا
ذلك امر اخر قد لا يحدث الزلف زال فعلا
لعدم السبب وعدم توفر معلومات دقيقه عن
اوزان وكتل الالواح الارضيه التي ستتحرك
الحل هو وضع استراتيجيه انذار مبكر لاتخاذ
الحيطه والحذر واجراءات السلامه لاخلاء
المدينه فادي الكوارث ولزياده احتماليه
التكهن بوقوع الزلزال ساعمل على تصميم
موديل حسابي او حاسوبي ذكي يعتمد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي يغذى بذاته ضخمه من
سيناريو زلزالي لمئه او مئتين سنه ماضيه
مع تحليل الوضعي الكوكبي عند كل زلزال حدث
في تلك الفتره يعني بالتالي ستدعم هذه
النظريه بهذا الجهاز شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
شكرا على هذه المقابله كنت معنا دكتور
صالح من عبر سكايب الدكتور صالح محمد عوض
شكرا اذا يجب ان نذكر بالعاجل الذي ورد
قبل قليل الدفاع المدني السوري يؤكد
انتهاء ويعلن انتهاء اعمال انتشار الضحايا
في اللاذقيه نذكر ان اللاذقيه كانت من بين
المحافظات الاربعه المنكوبه اللاذقيه
وطرطوس ماء عفوا حماه حلب وادلب خمسه
مقاطعات ضربها الزلزال والان كما نشاهد
مشاهدينا هذه لا زلنا في هاتاي في انطاكيا
نحاول ان نبقى مع هذه العمليه عمليه
الانقاذ التي يقف فيها موفد العربيه عمار
هندي منذ ساعات
فهذه الان يبدو انها تشارف على نهايتها
العمليه ولكن ايضا كانت كاميرا العربيه
الكثير من عمليات الانقاذ في مناطق مختلفه
ومن بينها
وسنتابع ايضا في كهرمان مرعش الان في
الجانب الايمن من الشاشه ايضا كانت قبل
قليل هناك عمليه انقاذ تكللت بالنجاح
وايضا سنستمر الان لمشاهده المزيد ونتمنى
ان يخرج من هذا الموقع يعني المزيد من
الاحياء ربما يبعثون الامل لجميع
الموجودين تحت وطاه هذه الكارثه منذ سته
ايام وحتى الان ساعود اليك عمار الان عمار
لو تعطينا تفاصيل التطورات في هذه العمليه
حتى هذه اللحظه العمليه مستمره وتتركز في
تلك الفتحه التي قاموا باحداثها في سقف
المبنى تمهيدا للوصول الى هذه السيده التي
توجد تتواجد تحت الانقاض وبحسب الاجهزه
التي يستخدمونها فهي حيه وبحسب ما الفحص
يعني معها والحديث معها تبين انها حيه
وهذا ما اثبتته الاجهزه الطبقيه واجهزه
استشعار الصوت وغيره ولكن يبدو ان هنالك
ما يعترضهم ويبدو ان التقدم بطيء حنين
وهذا هذه العقد
موجوده ورايناها في اكثر من مكان ويعني
كان الله في عونهم على هذه الجهود
المبذوله تحديدا مع الهزه الارتداد
الارتداديه نعود ونذكر في في
السابق قبل اقل من عشر دقائق كنت قد ذكرت
انها وقعت هزه ارتداديه بينما كانت هذه
العمليه جاريه وشعرت بها عمار ربما هذه
تؤخر هل هل تحدث اي تغيير هل حدث اي تغيير
في عمليه الانقاذ هل اثرت على هذا المبنى
ام كانت بس عمليه تعطيل لوقت قصير
احدثت قليلا ارباك لدى الجميع ورجال
الانقاذ صرخوا بانه لا يتحرك احد يعني هم
لديهم خبره في التعامل معها لانه في حال
تحرك هذا العدد الهائل من الموجودين على
سقف المبنى مع تزامنا مع الهزه ربما يعني
يؤثر اكثر على المبنى وتماسك السقف الذي
نقف عليه وبالتالي هي ربما يعني تدخل في
حساباتهم ولكنهم عادوا واستمروا بشكل
طبيعي ويعملون بشكل طبيعي ولكن هذه الهزات
الارتداديه حنين خطيره للغايه يعني لانه
تكون المباني المهدده بالانهيار والمباني
التي يعمل فيها رجال الانقاذ طبعا عرضه
للسقوط والانهيار مجددا وبالتالي هو خطر
كبير على رجال الانقاذ وهذا الذي نتحدث
فيه
المنهار في محيط هذا البناء المنهار هل
رصدت اهالي لربما هناك من يقرب من هذه
الامراه او الفتاه التي يعني تتم عمليه
انتشالها من تحت الانقاض هل هل رصدت اي من
اقربائها هناك
للاسف لا لم نرصد ولكنني رصدت اقرباء
لاشخاص اخرين سالتف بالكاميرا واعود الى
هذا المشهد ولكن ساشير بيدي تلك النيران
المشتعله هناك هذه لعائله سوريه تنتظر
قال لي شاب بانه والدته واشقاؤه لا يزال
تحت انقاذ هذا المبدا وهنالك اليات تعمل
للوصول اليهم يعني هذا هو المشهد في من
حول هذا هذه البؤره التي نسلط الضوء عليها
سالتفت اكثر بالكاميرا مع الزميل المصور
حتى تشاهدي ما الذي يحدث هنا هنالك ايضا
عمليات وهنالك عمليات تجري الان عمليه
انقاذ تجري هنالك طبعا اناس هذه النيران
كل هذه النيران المشتعله حنين هي لاسر
اشخاص
ينتظروا عائلاتهم التي لا تزال افراد منها
متواجده تحت الانقاض والمشهد بالتالي مرعب
جدا يعني نحن نقف على سطح مبنى نترقب
عمليه انقاذ
هل هل مهم من سكان نفس المباني حنين اعتذر
نعم
تم حفر هذه الحفره بدقه شديده
باليات جدا دقيقه وفيما هذه المرحله
الحساسه تحديدا سبقها وضع الواح خشبيه
وحتى حديديه ربما لتدعيم هذه الحفره بشكل
اقوى في استكمال عمليه الحفر الدقيق اذا
هذا الفريق ربما هو مكون من اكثر من 20
شخصا يقف الان على هذه العمليه
اذا وفي المقابل ايضا تجري عمليه قهرمان
مرعش في الجزء الايمن من الشاشه نشاهد
ايضا هناك عمليه انقاذ يقف فيها موفنه
ايضا غساله ابولوز يتابع وكانت قد تكللت
عمليه سابقه قبل اقل من ساعه بالنجاح في
هذا الموقع تحديدا اذا
اعيننا مع هذه العمليه سواء في قهرمان
مرعش او فيها تاي
وسنعود اليها كلما جد جديد اذا اثبتت عدد
من الدراسات على مدار السنوات الماضيه ان
للزلازل اثار نفسيه كبيره واحده من هذه
الدراسات التي نشرت عام 2016 على اجريت
على 76 الف متضرر من زلازل مختلفه اكدت ان
واحدا من كل اربع ناجين اربعه ناجين من
الزلزال يعاني من اضطرابات ما بعد الصدمه
اثار الزلازل النفسيه لا تقل عن الجسديه
اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه واكتئاب شديد
واحد من كل اربعه ناجين عانى من اضطراب ما
بعد الصدمه
دراسه في 2016 على 76 الف شخص من ضحايا
زلازل مختلفه
كيف يتم التعامل مع الحاله النفسيه اشعار
الناجين بالراحه التامه السؤال عن احوالهم
بشكل مستمر
مرحله التعافي المرحله الاولى هي الاكثر
صعوبه يتخللها دعم نفسي واجتماعي المرحله
الثانيه الاهتمام بسلوكيات الناجي من
الزلازل
من عمان ينضم الينا الطبيب النفسي الدكتور
عبد الله ابو العدس لنتحدث عن هذه الاثار
النفسيه
للناجين والمتضررين من هذه الزلازل سنتحدث
عن هذا الزلزال ربما بالتحديد لناخذه
كمثال عواقب وحسابات الكارثه بعد وقوعها
كثيره هذا فقط باب يعني اخر نفتحه الان
ربما مبكرا في ظل وصول عداد الضحايا الى
27 و500
27,500 قتيل ولكن يعني نود ان نعرف منك
دكتور عن هذه الاضطرابات ما بعد الصدمه
بحسب الدراسه التي كانت الان عرضناها 76
الف شخص اجريت عليهم الدراسه ونشرت في لوس
انجلوس تايمز تقول ان واحد من كل اربعه
اشخاص يعانون من هذا الاضطراب يعني
بوستروما او ما بعد الصدمه خاصه في هذه
هذا النوع من الكوارث الزلازل تحديدا
مساء الخير سيدتي يعني نترحم على من فقدنا
ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى ونتمنى ان
نجد من يتنسم انفاس الحياه من بين هذه
الانقاذ حقيقه هذا الزلزال شكل صدمه للوعي
الجمعي العالمي اجمع وطبعا الصدمه لمن
عايش الزلزال لمن هو موجود في ارض الميدان
ولمن شاهد ولمن سمح حقيقه هذا الحدث
الماساوي بكل الاحوال طبعا خلال المرحله
الاولى يصاب الانسان باضطراب الصدمه الحاد
وهذا الاضطراب هو عباره عن حاله من ازاله
الغلاف السايكولوجي النفسي الذي يحيط
بالانسان وبالتالي الان تزيد لديه الشعور
او مشاعر عدم اليقين عدم الشعور بالامان
النفسي وعدم الشعور حقيقه بالامان
الاجتماعي بكل الاحوال وبعدها الان بعد
الاسابيع الاربعه الاولى بعض الاشخاص واحد
من اربعه كما ذكر التقرير يعاني من
البوستروسين او متلازمه ما بعد الكرب او
ما بعد الصدمه وطبعا هذه المتلازمه نستطيع
ان نرصدها حقيقه وهنا الاهميه لانه الان
عند بدايه الان الاسعافات العضويه
للمصابين يجب ان نبدا بالاسعافات النفسيه
الاوليه والدعم السايكولوجي حقيقه حتى
الان نقلل الان من تحول هذه الحالات الى
متلازمه ما بعد الصدمه بكل الاحوال اذا
يجب ان نرصد علامات متلازمه ما بعد الصدمه
التي تشمل اضطرابات النوم اضطرابات الطعام
سهوله الانفعال العصبيه الغضب تشمل الشعور
بالذنب وجلد الذات نعم دكتور انت تعطينا
يعني مؤشرات يجب الالتفات اليها من قبل
المجتمع المحيط بالاشخاص الذين يتعرضون
لهذه الصدمات لكن ما هي الفئات الاكثر
التضررا من زلزال كهذا على سبيل المثال كل
له قصه ولكن من سيحمل معه هذه القصه طوال
حياته بمعاناه نفسيه لا تعالج
كل الفئات العمريه الان غير مستثناه حقيقه
من الاصابه السايكولوجيه يمكن ان تحدث
الصدمات الان بعد الزلزال خلال الزلزال
ويمكن ان تحدث بعد سنوات طويله حقيقه
والكل سيحمل معه جزء من هذه حقيقه الاصابه
النفسيه لنقل المؤلمه بكل الاحوال لكن
طبعا تختلف يختلف هذا الموضوع حسب درجه
المناعه النفسيه وحسب الفئه العمريه
فالاطفال كبار السن مثلا من فقدوا اناس
عزيزين عليهم هم اكثر الان عرضه حقيقه
لاخذ متلازمه الفقدان معهم لفترات طويله
من عمرهم بكل الاحوال لكن الاكثر على درجه
المناعه النفسيه
نعم الاطفال وكبار السن هذه من الفئات
الاكثر هشاشه حقيقه التي يمكن ان تحمل
معها هذه الندوب والاثار السايكولوجيه
لفترات طويله من عمرها يمكن ان تكون بعد
سنوات طويله من هذا المصاب الجلل الذي حدث
في تركيا وسوريا
تتحدث
[موسيقى]
عيبا ربما تبدا يعني اعراض تظهر عن اكتئاب
مزمن يعني هل هذا مختلف عن البوستروما او
ما بعد الصدمه
هو نفس الانظمه سياق البوستروما او ما بعد
الصدمه يعني خلال الاسابيع الاربعه الاولى
لنتكلم عن الصدمه النفسيه الحاده ومن ثم
نتكلم عن متلازمه ما بعد الصدمه القصد في
هذا الطرح الاعراض ممكن ان تحدث بعد سنه
او سنتين او ثلاث وتشمل اعراض الاكتئاب
واعراض القلق كما قلنا بعض اعراض الذهان
احيانا اعراض اضطرابات النوم اعراض الان
نوعا ما حقيقه التقوقع والعزله يعني هذا
الزلزال الان مع كل هزه ارتداديه تحدث
تصيب الناس هزه نفسيه هذه الهزه النفسيه
تفقدهم الشعور بالامان يدخلوا في حاله
الان من عدم اليقين من هم تحت الانقاض
الان كيف هي مشاعرهم حاله من الارتباك
حاله من الحيره حاله الان نوعا ما بين
اضطراب التركيز اضطراب التفكير حاله من
الالم بسبب الجوع والعطش والبرد وحال الان
نوعا ما حقيقه من صراع البقاء والفناء
وبالتالي هذه الان نوعا ما المركبات
السايكولوجيه يحملها الناجي معه وبالتالي
تحدث الان ضرر نسبي عند هذا الانسان تختلف
نسبته حسب درجه المناعه النفسيه ودرجه
الدعم النفسي السيكولوجي الاولي وهذا يجب
ان يعتبر اولويه من الفرق التخصصيه والفرق
العامه التي تستطيع تقديم هذا النوع من
الدعم عاده متى يبدا يا دكتور الالتفات في
هكذا حالات متى يبدا الالتفات الى الجانب
النفسي
منذ اللحظه الاولى للانقاذ سيدتي منذ
اللحظه الاولى للانقاذ يجب ان يكون هناك
الان دعم سيكولوجي عن طريق الان الاحاطه
بالمصاب عن طريق حقيقه محاوله الان نوعا
ما اعطاءه مجال للكلام اذا كان صامت
نستطيع التعامل معه من خلال لغه الجسد اذا
كان الان حقيقه في حاله من الهستيريا يجب
علينا ان نهدئ هذه الحاله ومن ثم نبدا
نرصد اعراض اضطراب النوم او اعراض الخوف
الشديد او الهلع ومن ثم الان نحول الاشخاص
المختصين حتى يبداوا بالعلاجات التخصصيه
فالرعايه النفسيه يجب ان تبدا منذ اللحظه
الاولى لانقاذ الاشخاص بكل الاحوال او لمن
شاهد او لمن سمع عن هذه الاصابات بكل
الاحوال يعني من هم خلف الشاشه يعانون
كذلك وسيعانوا من اضطرابات حقيقه الان
تختلف درجاتها بحسب الان كما قلنا المناعه
النفسيه وتشمل اضطرابات النوم ممكن ان
تشمل تدني المزاج الخوف
قاسيه على الجميع فماذا لو كانت يعني
تجربه يعيشها شخص من الانقاذ اشكرك جزيل
الشكر كنت معنا من عمان الطبيب النفسي
الدكتور عبد الله ابو العدس
الكاميرات الحراريه
تقنيه تحدد اماكن الاحياء تحت الاوقات
هذه التقنيه يمكنها استشعار نبضات القلب
وتنفس تحت الارض وتحت ركم الاوقات
كشف ضربات القلب وحراره الجسم وتعمل
باستخدام الاشعه تحت الحمراء تعمل دون
تدخل من العامل البشري المراقب لها
استخدامات عسكريه ومدنيه منها الكشف عن
تسرب الغاز وعمليه البحث والالقاع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره وتتابعها
معكم الزميله رشا نبيل ونحن نتابع هذه
اللقطات من عمليات الانقاذ في هاتاي اليك
رشا